hi we're gonna talk about how to get a
hard drive working that just doesn't
seem to be recognized by computer this
is assuming the hard drive is not
actually bad if it is actually bad this
process will probably reveal that but
occasionally what happens is you go and
buy a new hard drive and it's been wiped
and hasn't been formatted when you put
it in your computer and try to install
an OS it just doesn't show up or you
just put it in your computer and it just
doesn't show up and you don't really
know what to do a lot of times it just
works but other times it's just like
give me something computer I'm gonna
show you what you basically need to do
to get it working in that case this
happens with Windows installs sometimes
- if you get a new hard drive pop it in
there and you just start trying to
install windows and windows just won't
see your hard drive it's kind of a weird
thing I'm surprised they haven't like
fixed or done something about yet but
here's what you do
alright so you got the hard drive this
is one that is of that case where it
just doesn't show up it's just like
nothing happens and you need something
to mount the hard drive you can actually
like shutdown in computer and hook it up
to your desktop or something as a
secondary hard drive or you can get
something like this here black X and
just mounts hard drives there's a
million different tools and things you
can buy off Amazon eBay and whatnot to
mount hard drives externally so this is
just an external mount that I'm using
and let's see here
so my monitor screens down there that's
why I keep looking down so what you do
is well with the black X the way it
mounts is you just pop it in there and
then you turn on the black X and now if
the hard drive already has a volume it's
already set up it'll usually pop up and
ask you what you want to do or you can
go to your my computer which will do
here I'm gonna go ahead and make my face
a little smaller now all right here we
go open up your folder go to this PC on
windows 10 here and there's my three
hard drives in my computer but this new
one isn't showing up this one here is
just not showing up
so what you need to do is go to your
Start menu you can't see my Start menu
let me drag it up for a second and type
in Disk Management and you'll find this
in the control panel create and format
hard disk partitions you open that up
and this right away sees it and says you
must initialize disk before local disk
management can actually access it so
it's not initialized and you can just
hit OK here and it'll do it that's
generally what will happen so suddenly
I'll scroll make this figure here so if
you've never used this before basically
it gives you a little list up here and
down here is all your disks so there's
my three that are hooked up I don't want
to mess with those those are all fine
but here's the new one that's plugged in
111 point seven nine gigabytes that's
right it's a 128 gigabyte SSD so it's
got an unallocated amount here now that
it's an initialized it will actually
work you can you can go connected to
your laptop or whatever and start
installing something and now we'll be
seen but often those installers for
installing an OS they won't be able to
do the initial initialization so needs
initialized and you can do it this way I
usually just go ahead and make a quick
volume just to confirm that everything
works and I end up reformat it they
install anyway but there we go it seems
to be fine if you want to check it
further you can go back to to this area
and you can right click on it go to
properties and go to tools and then
check and you can check it for errors
scan your drive so you might want to do
that too if you want to be sure that it
doesn't have any problems and there you
go now you can go use your drive as
intended and not be mysteriously
confused as to why it never shows up
hope you enjoyed this video give it a
like and if you did and subscribe to the
channel if you want to see more tech
stuff thanks again and goodbye